(lively music)
Martin: Welcome to Future Talk, the show
that examines the global
impact of technology
both for good and for bad.
Our society is heavily
dependent on technology,
but maintaining that technology requires
people who are very well-educated
especially in math and science.
Our methods of teaching math have
hardly changed in the
past several centuries.
That may be about to change.
I have three guests to discuss
some of the new approaches
to teaching mathematics.
Peter Friess is president and CEO
of the Tech Museum of Innovation
which is the underwriter for this program,
and he's also an experienced clockmaker.
Keith Devlin is a mathematician,
and executive director
of Stanford University's H-Star Institute
which studies the relationship
between people and technology.
He won the 2007 Carl Sagan Award
for science outreach activities,
and is known to NPR listeners
as the Math Guy on Weekend Edition.
He's written 28 books and
is now working on a project
to use video game technology
to help middle school
students learn mathematics.
Salman Kahn is the founder
of the Kahn Academy which is a
one-man internet venture that aims
to provide free, world-class education
to anyone anywhere in the world.
His 1400 plus videos on YouTube have
garnered over 16 million views,
and have received glowing testimonials
from all over the world.
Kahn Academy is now the most popular
open education K through 12
education resource on the internet.
It's recently been profiled
on CNN, NPR, and the PBS NewsHour.
Salman received the 2009
Microsoft Education Award
at the Tech Museum in San
Jose for using technology
to benefit humanity.
I'd like to welcome all of
you to the program tonight.
Peter, let me start with you.
What is the Tech Museum doing
to advance new math education?
Peter: First of all if you go to a museum
especially to a science museum
like the Tech Museum is, then
there is math everywhere.
In every object you have math somehow.
What is the difference to
the normal school industry?
When you come to a museum, you have
to explore the space for yourself.
You have to be very active and
it's up to you what you learn.
Parallel to this, the Tech Museum offers
some very interesting programs.
One, especially, is
where we bring teachers,
kids and parents together in one classroom
because as we always know, kids go home
and say, "I have a problem to understand,"
and you have to have education
from your parents so sometimes parents
don't even have learned themselves
what's now going on at school;
therefore, building this triangle
between teacher, kids, and parents is a
very, very helpful thing and
that happens at the Tech Museum.
Martin: Is this sort of an experimental
prototype where you're experimenting
with different ways of learning
the role of the parent,
the role of the teacher,
the role of the student himself?
Peter: Exactly. The
Tech Museum would not be
in Silicon Valley if we would not do
these kind of experiments all the time.
We are looking for new ways of how
to bring these difficult subjects closer
to the people that people
really can make use
of what they've learned in the museum
in becoming a global
citizen, a well-informed
citizen about science that problems
like we have them right now
down in Florida, cannot
happen or are going
to be treated in a much different way.
Martin: Does this approach, does it get
outside the museum so where, for example,
school districts are
watching your experiments
and what you're doing,
and seeing how they could
apply it to their own teaching?
Peter: Yeah. We are working
together with teachers.
We're working together with the kids,
and we let them participate
in building the museum.
For instance, we have a program right now
where kids are in front
of teachers getting
educated on a science
subject for about 20 minutes.
Then they have to repeat
what they've learned in front
of a camera and these videos
are really, really good.
They show us what people
can learn in 20 minutes,
and how they explain what
they've learned to the audience.
Those videos finally end
up in the museum itself
in front of the science experiment
so the video basically
with the kid on the video
explains the science experiment.
There are no labels anywhere.
Martin: Well, I gather
that there is a need
to upgrade teaching
because it hasn't really
changed much lately, and
the needs have changed.
Keith, how long has it
been since there has been
a major upgrade to the
way mathematics is taught?
Keith: Well, the three
images that I brought along
to show to the audience
are from a book that was
written in 1202. It's by Leonardo of Pisa.
It was written in Latin.
It's called Liber Abaci. It
means the book of calculation.
Martin: Yeah, can we see those pictures?
I think we have those images.
Let's go ahead and show those pictures.
Keith: This book appears in 1202.
It was the first arithmetic book that ever
appeared in Western Europe.
It looks very little different from an
arithmetic book today except
that the language is changed.
We don't write our books in Latin anymore.
They've got a little bit thinner.
That was about 600 pages, but essentially
arithmetic teaching hasn't changed
in the West in 800 years.
Martin: Now one might say
if a system has worked
for 800 years, why does
it need to change now?
Keith: I think many people in our audience
will say that it hasn't worked very well.
We've been using it, we've used textbooks
because for 800 years
that was the only way
we could capture mathematical knowledge
on any kind of device
that we could distribute
to a large number of
people. It had to be text,
but mathematics isn't about facts.
Mathematics is a way of thinking
about the world, problems in the world.
it's something you do.
What's the best way to learn
something you do? You do it.
If you want to learn to play chess,
you can learn the rules from a book,
but you won't learn to play
chess until you play the game.
If you want to learn to play tennis,
the book will tell you something,
but you've got to go out and play tennis.
You can't always learn by going out
and doing the real thing,
for example, if you want
to learn how to fly an airplane,
you learn in a simulator.
If you want to learn how
to be a brain surgeon,
you will be trained in a simulator.
The U. S. Army uses
simulators to train troops
before they go to Iraq.
Martin: How does this
apply to mathematics?
Keith: Mathematics learning is more like
learning to be a soldier because there's
a danger element that
people will get scared.
The best way to learn
mathematics is either
in a real-world environment
where you're using
mathematics, and those are difficult
to come across especially with classes
full of students, or you
learn it in a simulator.
The modern word for a
simulator is a video game.
That's why I've spent the last five years
looking at how you can use video games,
massively, multiplayer, online games
to provide environments in which students
can learn mathematics
in a real environment.
Martin: When you talk
about teaching people
how to think mathematically,
what does that look like?
How does a person who
thinks mathematically differ
from a person who does
not think mathematically?
Keith: In almost every respect.
For example, we don't
get nervous when numbers
are bounded around. We
know what the numbers mean.
We know that if the
prices go up 10% this week
and come down 10% next
week, they don't go back
to where they were. We
just have this sense
of what the numbers mean,
and what video games
are ideal for, you can use
them for doing all kinds
of mathematics, but what they're ideal for
is getting people to that familiarity
with numbers and
quantities that are really
part and parcel of being a
citizen in the 21st Century
in a country like the United States.
Martin: We're getting
away from the traditional
rote learning where you
just memorize everything
whether you really understand it or not.
Keith: Mathematics today
more than at any time
in history, it's important to be able
to think like a mathematician.
You actually no longer need to do a lot
of the detailed mathematics.
We have machines like this device
that Peter's got next to me that will
do mathematics for us.
We have computers to do that.
We have check-out machines
at the supermarket
doing the calculations.
It's not as important as
it was when I was a child.
Thinking mathematically, that's the kind
of the realm in the 21st Century.
Martin: I think the students of the future
will be very happy to
learn that they'll be able
to spend their math class
playing video games.
Keith: I would hope they
would because learning
math should be fun, and by
golly, we can make it fun.
Martin: Now you're
working on this project.
Where is this project?
Is this game ready to
roll off the shelves?
Keith: Absolutely not. We
started off five years ago
thinking that this might cost
$30, $40, $50 million dollars.
My current estimate is this is a
$500 million dollar operation at least.
I'm now calling this the Apollo Program
in mathematics education.
It's the educational equivalent of putting
some person on the moon.
We want to put some
person into a mathematical
mind and just keep them
alive, if you would.
It's got to be a big national program.
This is not something that even a large
video game company can do.
This has to be a national
initiative because
that's the only way to do
something on this scale.
Martin: That's very interesting because
you're talking about a $500 million dollar
expenditure to build this video program.
Now Sal, you've created Khan Academy
which essentially provides free education
which costs next to nothing to produce,
and you've had 16 million viewers already.
What is Khan Academy actually?
And how does it really work?
Sal: Yes, so most people know it as
this library of 1400 videos on YouTube.
As you mentioned, it's
gotten 16 million views.
It's now the most viewed open
education library, more than
especially on YouTube,
more than MIT and Stanford.
All of the videos have been made by me.
I'm the faculty of the Khan Academy.
The goal is to, I'm going
to keep making videos,
but we're supplementing
that with a software piece,
and eventually build a
community around the site
so that students can
start teaching each other.
The goal is really to
be a free virtual school
for the world, a place where anyone can go
to the site and learn at their own pace,
get feedback, get data
on what they're doing
and start at any point
and get to any point.
If you go to the site right now,
you'll see there's a video
literally on 1 + 1 = 2.
That's the very first arithmetic video.
The videos, 1400 videos
is a lot of material,
and it goes all the way up to the last
calculus video I did
was a surface integral
and you can go into
differential equations,
and physics, and there's even stuff
on the financial crisis and all of that.
The goal is to start at a basic level
and go as far as you need to go.
Martin: Before we discuss
Khan Academy further,
we're actually going to view some excerpts
from some of your videos.
What are we going to
see in these excerpts?
Sal: The one thing that I think stands out
to a lot of people is that the form factor
for the Khan Academy is fairly different
than what you would
expect as online video.
You're not going to see the instructor.
You're not going to see
someone at a whiteboard
kind of teaching away from you.
All you see is a black background,
some writing in different
colors that look nice,
and a voice, and I like to
end the voice as this voice.
I like to think that it's
more of an experience
of me sitting next to you and we're doing
a tutoring session, or
me being in your head
more of an intimate kind
of one-on-one tutoring
informal type of a framework.
Martin: We're going to go
ahead and roll that video.
Let's take a look at Sal's video,
and then we'll come back
and discuss it further.
Let's roll that tape.
Sal: Notice we interpreted the statement
in two different ways.
This was just straight left to right doing
the addition, then the multiplication.
This way we did the multiplication first
then the addition. We got
two different answers.
That's just not cool in mathematics.
If this was part of some
effort to send something
to the moon because two people interpreted
it in a different way, or one computer
interpreted it one way, another computer
interpreted it another way, the satellite
might go to Mars. This is
just completely unacceptable.
That's why we have to have an agreed upon
order of operations, an agreed upon way
to interpret this statement.
The agreed upon order of operations
is to do parentheses first.
Let me write it over here,
parentheses. Parentheses first.
Then do exponents. If you don't know what
exponents are, don't worry
about it right now. Exponents.
In this video we're not going to have
any exponents in our examples so you don't
really have to worry
about them for this video.
Then you do multiplication.
I'll just right mult,
short for multiplication.
The you do multiplication
and division next.
They kind of have the
same level of priority.
Then finally, you do
addition and subtraction.
Finally, you do addition and subtractions.
A neuron can be a
reasonably normal sized cell
although there is a huge range,
but the axons can be quite long.
They could be short sometimes in the brain
you might have very small axons,
but you might have axons that go down the
spinal column or that go
along one of your limbs,
or if you're talking about a dinosaur,
going along one of a dinosaur's limbs.
The axon can actually
stretch several feet.
Not all neuron's axons are several feet,
but they could be, and this is really
where a lot of the distance
of the signal gets traveled.
Let me draw the axon.
The axon will look something like this,
and at the end it ends
at the axon terminal
where it can connect to other dendrites,
or maybe to other types
of tissue or muscle
if the poor point of this neuron is
to tell a muscle to do something.
Let's say I go to the local grocery store.
Let me draw that in orange.
Let's say I go to some
grocery store over here.
I'll say G for grocery,
and I buy $100 worth
of groceries and I want to pay with my
newly issued credit card.
Let me write this down.
This is the issuing, issuer.
This is the issuing bank.
I go to the grocery store.
I say, "Hey, I'd like to
pay with a credit card."
The grocery store, if
they accept credit cards,
they need to have some relationship with
another bank someplace
on this Visa network
in order for them to accept a Visa card.
Let's say that they have a relationship
with Bank B over here.
This would be the merchant bank,
or we could say the retailers bank,
or it's often in credit card lingo
called the acquiring
bank, or the acquirer.
You might wonder why is
it called the acquirer?
It's called the acquirer
because this is the
player that goes out and
goes to each of the merchants
and says, "Hey, right
now you only accept cash,
"or you only accept American Express.
"Wouldn't it be great if you also
"accepted Visa or Mastercard?
"That way you'll have more appeal to more
"customers and it will be more convenient
"for your customers and every time a
"transaction happens, we'll just take
"a little bit of a cut
of that transaction."
So they go out and acquire
different retailers.
Martin: That was some sample
videos from Kahn Academy.
I like your style of delivery
because I don't think
you're going to lose anyone.
It's kind of folksy. You're
not rushing through it,
but it looks like the videos
are very simple to produce.
It looks like they cost
next to nothing to create.
Is there anything preventing other people
from also jumping into this field
and creating their own similar videos.
Sal: No, and I hope they do it.
Literally to produce these videos
I think some of the people at home
could start doing it tonight.
You just need a little
pen tablet you can get
at the local electronics
store for under $100.
I use Screen Capture. You
can get a shareware version.
Then I'm just using an art program.
I started doing Microsoft Paint.
I'm now using other slightly more fancy
shareware pieces of programming,
but it's very simple, very easy.
I started doing it just
because I was remotely
tutoring my cousins in New Orleans,
and when I was doing that we just had
a shared whiteboard and
we didn't see each other,
and it seemed to work so I figured why not
do the same thing then
I wouldn't have to get
a camera crew and all that.
Martin: How are the videos used?
Is this something that
a person just watches
at home alone, or can this be brought into
a classroom situation?
Sal: When I started, I envisioned it being
some type of a supplemental
material for students
when they're home if
they need to remediate,
fill in gaps in their knowledge,
they can just dive in and
get a 10 minute nugget
that fills in a basic building block.
They can pause and repeat
it as much as they want.
I've gotten a lot of feedback.
It's starting to be used in the classroom.
Really it's an organic process.
It makes a lot of sense if
you think about it right now.
I've gotten an email
from a teacher in London
that said, "We've flipped the model.
"We are now, instead of doing lecture
"in the classroom, and homework at home,
"I now assign Kahn Academy videos at home
"where the students can
watch it at their own pace,
"at their own time, pause and repeat,
"fill in the gaps in their knowledge,
"and then when you come to the classroom,
"then you do your homework.
"Then you can get the benefit of a teacher
"being around. The
teacher can observe what
"the students are doing,
and the students can help
"each other so you're
actually taking advantage
"of the social aspects of a classroom
"to actually teach each other."
It can be used either.
It could be used for a home school.
I've gotten letters from parents who,
one, they use it for their
kids, but they also use it
to stay ahead of their
kids so that they can
teach them one step ahead.
It's really I'm learning
of new applications
for it every day.
Martin: How do the teachers know
that the kids master the material?
Would they still have the
same traditional test?
Or could you have a thing
where a child finishes
one video. they somehow
demonstrate that they've
absorbed what it taught,
and then they go on
to the next video so people
kind of work at their own pace?
Sal: Yeah. When I
started the Kahn Academy,
it's most known for the videos,
but there's an entire software piece
that I started really
building for my cousins
and now several tens
of thousands of people
are using the software.
The idea is you start everyone at 1 + 1.
There's these little modules.
People can log in right now
and start working on it.
It starts at 1 + 1 = 2,
and the paradigm isn't
get 80% right and you're a C student,
or 90% right and you're a B,
or 95% and you're an A student.
The paradigm is get ten in a row
because even if you're an A student
and you've gotten 95%
right, what was that 5%?
In math, I think we can all
appreciate in mathematics,
if you have even a 5% gap, when you build
on top of that, you don't
know what something is
to the zero power, then when you see it
in calculus, you're
like, "Gee, I don't know.
"I was an A student,
but I still didn't know
"that one special case."
So the paradigm is get ten in a row,
and as you get ten in a row you get,
and while you're doing the modules
it's tracking everything,
every interaction
with the actual software,
so if you think about it
you're getting instruction from the video.
You're getting practice and feedback
directly from the software in real time,
and then everything is being tracked
so it's actual real-time assesment
that's actionable that the teachers
can actually get data on what
to do about what students.
Everyone is working at their own pace.
Martin: Of course, the
tradition is that everybody
goes in lock step which
is bad in two respects.
One respect, the slow
kids get left behind.
The other respect is that
the fast kids are held back.
Sal: The real irony is sometimes there's
a flipping of, we've
had the experience where
this is easy and you're kind of bored.
Then all of a sudden,
"Wait, I missed that."
You've now fallen behind
and I've seen it in the data
of students using the software is that
sometimes a student will,
when they're working
at their own pace, a
student that you might say
is slow initially because
they're spending more time
on one concept, once they
get that out of the way,
they race forward so
it's actually very hard
to predict who are the
slow or the fast students.
Just going back to the traditional model
on some level we've gotten so used to it
because it's 1,000 years old,
but we don't question
this idea of passively
getting lectures, then you
go home and you do things
in a vacuum, and you
keep doing that process
for several days and then you
get a snapshot assessment.
When you get the assessment, it tells you
you knew 80% of that concept.
In a normal world when
you're learning something,
if I only know how to ride
a bike 80% of the way,
I'm going to keep sitting on that bike
until I can always before
I try out a unicycle.
Martin: A lot of people seem to have
a real math phobia. I've
known people who just
don't believe they can
understand anything in math.
It might be because they missed one
like it's a chain of
knowledge and if one link
in the chain is broken, then you lose
the rest of the chain,
but here you don't
advance to the next link
until you're sure that
you've mastered this link.
Sal: Right. There's a couple of reasons.
I'm convinced that a
lot of the frustration
that goes on in say an algebra class isn't
because the student is slow,
or because the teacher is bad.
It's just that the student has a weakness
in borrowing numbers, or negative numbers.
There's no way in that algebra class
to address that negative number.
The student might not even know
that they have that basic weakness
in negative numbers and they just keep
talking past each other.
I think you're exactly right.
That's the problem is
that no matter how good
you do in traditional model,
how good the actors are in it,
if you have this basic core weakness,
there's no way to address
it in the traditional model.
Martin: Let me throw out a question that
any of you can feel free to answer.
Is learning itself an art?
The usual model is that the child is
a passive vessel in which
you pour the knowledge.
Is learning something
that you have to know
how to do like you have
to learn how to learn
before you can even start?
Peter: At the museum, the game program,
and in your methodology really teaches us
and we learn it that
there is a different way
of learning where you are the master
of the speed how fast you learn.
You go forwards and
backwards. It's your choice.
People who come to museums,
they give random a chance.
The run around. They
discover their talents.
The learning is not working
in the future I think
with a teacher outside and
a lot of kids sitting there
and just watching at this teacher.
I think we want to be part
of this learning process,
and we want to really
organize it ourselves.
I think in all of our three cases
that's happening nowadays.
Keith: That's the power of a video game.
In a video game, the player is the star
of that universe. It revolves around you.
They're designed that way.
Remember human beings as a species,
we survived because we learned to learn.
We are the learning species.
We are programmed from birth to learn
in an environment where
it's important to learn.
Peter: And you're getting
immediately feedback.
Keith: And you get immediate feedback.
Just as with Sal's, video game learning
it reverses everything.
What does the teacher say?
Go home tonight. Your homework
is to acquire the Sword of Doom.
We build that game so
acquiring the Sword of Doom
requires solving some math problems.
The child probably
won't solve the problems
that night so they go
back and the teacher says,
"Go look at Khan Academy and you'll find
on Video 35 exactly what you'll need
to go back in tomorrow night
and capture the Sword of Doom.
The child now is motivated
in a right environment,
and they've got all of
these sources available;
teacher, textbooks, videos.
Brings it all together.
Martin: I think a lot
of people who have made
the greatest contributions
in computer science
didn't make it because
of what they learned
sitting in classrooms.
It's what they did at home playing
and putting things together.
Kevin: They dropped out. Many
of them dropped out of school.
Sal: To your point about
this learning to learn,
and is there, I have a 15 month old son.
He is a natural learner
just likewhat these
guys are talking about.
That's all he wants to do.
In fact, if you take
him away from exploring
and playing with something,
and seeing and understanding,
that's what upsets him.
I think the problem isn't that we need
to teach people how to learn.
I think a lot of our current institutions
actually go in the opposite direction
of our natural learning instincts.
They force, even though
you want to be active
and engaged, and explore things,
they're treating you like a vessel
that needs information to be poured in.
Martin: Go ahead.
Peter: In 1980, that's now 30 years ago,
I learned Latin at a school.
I was not really good at Latin
so I bought one of the first laptops.
I put all the vocabulary of this book
into this little computer,
and the computer was asking me the word.
I typed it in, and when I typed
it correctly, it erased it.
If I made an error, it recorded it.
Then he asked me the wrong ones again.
I basically learned how to
program Basic in those days.
My Latin didn't really improve.
Martin: Instant feedback
is really important.
You don't pour knowledge
into the vessel all year,
and at the end of the
year you give a one-time
test to see what they learned.
Sal: And then move on if they didn't.
Martin: There are a lot of good methods
to improve education, but, for example,
here in the state of
California education is
a huge bureaucracy, and bureaucracies are
highly resistant to change.
Is there any way that some of the ideas
we're talking about could actually
find its way into this big
massive inertial system?
Sal: One thing I've seen just from letters
from Kahn Academy users, and I'm getting
a couple hundred every day now,
is that some students
are using Kahn Academy
as their primary
instruction, and they're just
showing up at their university
or their high school
just to kind of show what they've learned.
I think it's hard to change the system.
It's a big beast and you got to kind
of massage it slowly.
But I think over time when people find
these alternate sources for learning
their information and
professors start to say,
"Wait. Gee, people are just showing up.
"I'm just a test administrator.
"I'm not actually, they're
learning someplace else."
Hopefully, the system itself will say,
"Gee, maybe we need to reflect."
I don't understand why
there are 300 person
lecture rooms anymore.
If you think about it,
on-demand video is better
in every single way.
A 300 person lecture room
is a complete broadcast,
completely passive.
On-demand video you can pause,
repeat, watch at your own time.
The inertia of the bureaucracy
is continuing to do.
Even a 20 person classroom,
you have to question,
but 300 person, I can't,
I've challenged everyone.
No one can think of why this exists,
but at every university
you pay $30,000 a year.
They stick you in these rooms,
and you get a broadcast lecture.
Peter: I think we're in the middle of that
really social change
already. It's happening.
You prove it.
Keith: Jumping on the edges,
but it can happen on the edges
because one guy in a
converted closet can reach
16 million people.
Sal: Yeah.
Keith: I mean the technology
allows small groups
of people to make big change.
Martin: The internet
is really the backbone
of the change because that is what enables
the instant communication from anywhere
to anyone at almost no cost.
We're always looking for
new ways to apply this
and we're probably at the very beginning
of figuring out how to really apply it.
Sal: Yeah.
Martin: What's your
economic model for this?
You give the product away for nothing.
Sal: (laughs) That's a mysterious ...
I used to work in the hedge fund world.
I was an analyst and I was doing all
of this part time starting for my cousins
really then it started to take off.
In September, I just
felt, and it's all for a
not for profit basis.
Kahn Academy is a 501C3 organization.
We could talk about why
I decided to do that.
There was some temptation to go on a ...
Martin: People can donate without ...
Sal: Yeah. They can donate, but
then I'm limited doing this.
It was initially essentially self-funded.
There was some donations
coming from the viewers
just spontaneous donations.
There was a little bit of advertising
that's going to kahnacademy.org.
I wasn't taking a salary
until very recently.
Martin: Unfortunately, I'm
going to have to cut you off
because I just got the signal that we're
just about totally out of time.
Sal: Okay.
Martin: So we're going
to have to wrap the show.
I'd like to thank my three
very distinguished guests,
Peter Friess, Keith Devlin, Salman Kahn.
Thanks to all of you for being here
and advancing public knowledge on how
to improve math training
so we can continue
to maintain this huge technological
society we've created.
Thank you for watching.
Be sure to tune in next time.
I'm Marty Wasserman. See you next time.
(lively music)